Like Sara said, to share my
reflections repository on Get Hub,
I'll first need to create
a repository on Get Hub.
To do this, I'll make sure
I'm logged in by looking for
my username in this corner, and then on
any screen, I'll click the plus sign and
select new repository.
I'll name the repository reflections,
and I'll leave it as public.
Now, I don't want to initialize
the repository with a README.
If I were making a repository on git-hub
before I had created any content,
then I probably would check this box.
Because that way my repository would
start out with one commit in it.
You can't clone the repository with no
commit, so this is often a good idea.
But since I already have commits in
my repository that I want to share.
I wont check this box.
Next, I'll need to add this
repository as a remote to my
reflections repository, on my computer.
Just like I can use the command,
git branch, to view and
create branches, I can use the command,
git remote, to view and create remotes.
First I'll run the command
git remote with no arguments,
to see all the current remotes.
The output is empty because I
haven't added any remotes yet.
Next, to add the repository on GitHub as
a remote I'll run, git remote add, and
I'll supply the name I want to use.
Now I can use any name here and
it's the name that I'll use within this
repository, to refer to
the repository on GitHub.
If you only have one remote,
it's standard to name it origin,
so I'll do that.
Next, I'll need to supply a URL for
my remote.
I can find the URL on
the GitHub page where I just
created the reflections repository.
So I'll copy the URL, then paste it
into my command, then press Enter.
Now if I run git remote again, I can see
that the origin remote has been created.
To verify that the URL was added
correctly, i'll run git remote -v.
V stands for verbose, and means that git
remote will output more information.
That is, it will be more verbose.
The output shows both the URL
where I would fetch data from, and
the URL where I would push data to.
In most cases these
will be the same URL.
Here I can see the same
URL that I just pasted.
Now in order to send my changes to the
remote, I'll use the command git push.
Git push takes two arguments.
The remote I want to send changes to,
and
the name of the local branch
that I'd like to push.
I named my remote origin,.
And I've made all of my changes
in the local master branch.
So run git push origin master.
Before I ran Git Push,
I had made a bunch of changes in the
master branch on my local repository.
And my repository on Git Hub was empty.
Running git push copied all of the
commits reachable from my master branch
to origin.
That is my repository on Git Hub.
By default, the branch created on
Git Hub will have the same name as
the local branch that I pushed.
So this branch will
also be called master.
Now I'll refresh the page on GitHub.
And I can see that all my
files have been added.
I can also see here that
the branch I'm on is named master.
Now create a reflections repository
on your own GitHub account.
Then push your reflections from
your own computer to GitHub.
Post a link to your new reflections
repository on the forums.
Then take a minute to read some of
the other students' reflections.
You might not want to read their
reflections for lesson three yet though.
Their reflections will be more
valuable if you think about them for
yourself before reading what
other people have said.
Once you've shared a link to your
reflections repository, check this box.